introducing a massive Planet into the
solar system would create some serious
instabilities
our moon would experience extreme
changes in Tidal forces
this gravity could be strong enough to
pull the moon apart into teeny tiny
pieces the only Remnant you'd have left
would be a new ring of debris forming
around Earth so Earth wouldn't steal any
planets away but our super Earth could
have some effect on their orbit the
Earth would affect the orbits of other
celestial bodies like asteroids our
gravitational pull could be strong
enough to eject these objects from the
asteroid belt and set them on a
collision path with you
and that would be bad news